speaking of elon musk there are now
assets that trade based on who the
individuals are that are believed to be
supporting them and one of those assets
is shibu enu already i'm out with the
name but
recently he was asked did he own any
first he said something to the effect uh
not explicitly talking about shibuya but
he said out of curiosity i have acquired
some aussie hash strings called bitcoin
ethereum and doge that's it as i've said
before don't bet the farm on crypto true
value is building products and providing
services to your fellow human beings not
money in any form and so ultimately elon
continues to explain why he doesn't look
at himself as an investor instead he
simply looks at himself as a builder as
an innovator and as an entrepreneur
but
earlier this year
elon was obviously tweeting a bunch
about many many different
cryptocurrencies and so he was asked by
shibuenu holder on twitter hey elon how
much shebe are you holding and he said
nothing
and when he said none jameson lop had a
great point jamison said if you live by
the meme you die by the meme lord
and so when all of a sudden people
believe that somebody like elon he's
going to buy it because he thinks it's
funny he's going to buy it because he
thinks it's going to go up
well he's actually being pretty rational
he's saying don't go bet the farm on one
of these assets
i will be the first one to say it and
people will get upset
but this stuff
it's entertainment it's not true
investing
and when you start to understand that
it's entertainment sure you want to go
by a little bit knock yourself out but
understand what you're doing it's no
different than going to a casino it's no
different than going and actually
sitting at a movie and watching
something it's no different than going
and joining a local club or a community
that's what this stuff is
there is value in various assets across
markets
but when you start to look at the meme
coins
there's plenty of other people who are
going to tell you it's going to the moon
it's going up et cetera but the one
thing i promise you guys is i'll always
just shoot you straight
i wouldn't buy this
the reason why i wouldn't buy it is
because ultimately what you are trading
on is you're trading on market dynamics
that have no ability to be rooted in
reality
you're literally watching an asset that
goes up and down based on speculation of
who may own it
now when you actually look at the
underlying fundamentals of it and you
look at developer activity and all the
things that would drive true value
it's just not there and again it's fun i
get it i see the memes i see the people
tweeting at me they're funny no problem
just don't go put
20
50
of your portfolio in this stuff
there's nothing wrong with making a
non-economic decision with half a
percent of your portfolio
whatever people do it all the time they
buy something because oh i shop there i
don't necessarily think that the stocks
can go up but i shop there i like it i
want to support them sure
but do not confuse entertainment
and non-economic decision making with a
belief that something's going gonna go
up forever
and that ultimately i think is a lesson
that has to be learned over and over and
over again by people who come into the
market
is that
yes in the short term things can be
irrational they can be illogical but
over a long period of time
value accrues to things that actually
have use
who actually have adoption and who
actually have developers that are
willing to build around and on top of it
and i don't expect this to be a popular
opinion everyone loves the idea of
participating in a market where there's
some level of everyone getting rich
but somebody's got to say it and so i
think that this is a great point by
jameson is if you live by the meme you
die by the meme lord
and
you just never know
when the death can come right guys
yeah i mean i'm not buying any of that
i i i think yeah you just need to be
careful like everyone likes to have fun
uh even when it comes to investing and
these are uh assets we'll call them that
you can invest in and have fun and it's
a cool community i'm sure and people are
enjoying it but ultimately you want to
put the large percentage of your
portfolio or the money that you're
trying to compound over time into assets
that you that you uh agree will
appreciate over time and and will bring
more value to the world uh and have real
you to utility in use cases and this
doesn't appear to be one so i think the
idea that you would buy an asset based
on who's supporting it or just kind of
the general thought behind and to be
fair i don't even know if elon said he
was ever supporting it maybe i'm wrong
on that but it seems like he never owned
any at any point and doesn't own
anything you got a picture of his dog
that looks like the shiba dog oh so
that's where it came from and then
people started speculating yeah yeah
some people speculated again it's uh
it's not my my model to buy things that
uh
yeah celebrity maybe might be interested
in